hey everyone bandit here you know if you
peruse the elden ring lore and theory
sections of the interwebs for very long
there's one thing you'll find out for
sure different people have different
opinions people interpret things
differently and debate which
interpretation feels better but one
thing that nobody debates is the fact
that the lore of this game is in and of
itself debatable by nature listen don't
hate me for saying it i'm just the
messenger it's true if you called elden
ring's story vague or muddled or
confusing you'd be making an
understatement but this does result in
all the awesome elden ring theorizing
going on all the time that being said
though and being a part of the theory
presence on youtube myself i've come to
the conclusion that there are several
characters or concepts or events that
are simply left unanswered in the game
there's just no way around it and it
could be that these questions will be
answered in the future by way of story
dlc or something like that which is
definitely something that fromsoft is
known for but for now here are the 10
biggest unsolved mysteries from the game
please keep in mind that this is not all
of them just the 10 biggest in my
opinion and also there be spoilers in
the video you've been warned the first
one is something you see right off the
bat in the game and that is this dead
lady sitting right here in front of your
character when you spawn into the lands
between for the very first time the
building itself is called the chapel of
anticipation but that doesn't really
give us any hints as to what's going on
here we can theorize that this poor
murdered lady is most likely a finger
maiden but anything more than that is
just speculation we can talk about
whether the grafted scion just ahead was
the one who killed this lady or whether
or not she was actually your original
finger maiden and therefore her death is
why you're maidenless but ultimately
every possible detail about her is
simply unknown and nowhere to be found
yet in the game secondly it is still
unanswered as to who really gave you the
blessing of grace was it queen america
or the greater will itself the reason
why this is debatable is because we know
for a fact that queen america knew the
tarnished would return based on her own
dialogue that melano will dictate to us
in the game but the problem with
believing it was merica outright comes
from the timeline that is to say that
america knew the tarnish would return
then merica banished the tarnished and
removed their grace then merica
shattered the elden ring then america
was imprisoned within the archery then
the shattering war happened and then the
tarnished were granted blessings of
grace once again as you can see since
america was imprisoned well before the
tarnished were granted grace and since
the greater will speaks to the tarnished
via the fingers via enya it definitely
seems like the greater will was the only
entity capable of offering its own grace
to the tarnished at this time but this
still doesn't change the fact that it
was merica's plan for this to happen all
along and she was still a goddess
according to the greater will itself
regardless of being imprisoned so with
this question being unconfirmed we just
don't currently know for sure if the
greater will desperately gave grace to
the tarnished or america did according
to her own plan thirdly and speaking of
america and her plans honestly a lot of
her decisions have mysterious motives
but the chief of them all would be the
infamous shattering of the elden rink
you know the basis for the entire game
if we're being completely honest we
still do not know for sure why she did
it ronnie claims that it was because she
was grieving over the loss of her son
godwin but at the same time we have
proof that the black knife assassins
were connected directly to america
implying the whole assassination thing
might have been merica's plan all along
which conflicts with why she would be
feeling grief we also have proof of
america discussing the ring's shattering
with her husband slash other self before
it happened meaning it wasn't something
she did out of an emotional reflex it
was most likely planned the problem is
we don't know exactly what her plan or
motives were so the shattering of the
elden ring the namesake of the entire
game surprisingly remains a mystery
fourthly and speaking of america's hubby
slash other self the huge game changing
twist of fate wacky storytelling crazy
piece of lore is that radigan is merica
and that's confirmed in game directly
several times non-debatable but what
isn't confirmed is whether or not
ratigan was always america we know that
at one point they were separate beings
according to merica's own words when she
tells him directly that he ratigan is
yet to become her america ratigan was
also off making babies with his first
wife ranala the enemy of america by the
way while america was waging wars with
her first husband godfrey so yeah we
know they were separate but we don't
know if ratigan was a separate being in
the first place or was a creation of
america from her own essence since she
calls ratigan her other self in the same
sentence before they're joining i
personally tend to believe the latter
and go into that theory with much more
detail in the america explained video
but i'm not too proud to admit that this
isn't confirmed in the least so yeah
mystery number four is that it's not
confirmed whether or not ratigan was
always merica or a different individual
to begin with possibly explaining his
red hair next up is the mystery of what
makes an empirian an imperial and i can
already tell a lot of you are rolling
your eyes at this one but it's true
we've got people including myself
claiming it must be that an emperian is
an individual that is pure of god blood
which is why only those born of a quote
single god in game are imperians and
therefore fit to take the mantle of
being the elden rings vessel but this is
far from confirmed and for proof of that
just look at any post on reddit or
anywhere explaining the nature of an
empyrean or even my own recent videos
the other possible explanation is that
an emperian is simply an individual that
is chosen by an outer god by way of said
outer gods two fingers but of course
that's just speculation we do know what
it means to be an emperian but we're far
from having a confirmed answer as to
what makes an emperian number six is
another highly debated topic or should i
say another highly debated individual
ronnie the witch who is she how was she
born why is she an emperian and most
importantly why oh why is she so similar
to melina you're not finger maiden with
the whole closed tattooed eye thing in
the mentions of torrent and the
disappearing out of thin air in blue
particle magic i kid you not none of
these questions are confirmed anywhere
in game except for maybe who she is
since we know she is the daughter of
ranala and ratigan but even so we don't
actually know how she was born or what
her great rune was supposed to be before
she threw it away or the huge can of
worms that is who her teacher the snow
witch was and whether or not the snow
witch's name was rena which is the name
that ronnie falsely takes on when you
first meet her
so many questions and absolutely no
answers number seven is who was the
gloam-eyed queen or the dust guide queen
depending on what item description
you're reading seriously who was this
lady we can read that she was an
empyrean which i'm sure is an absolutely
crucial piece of information if only we
knew more about what makes it empirian
and appearing and we know that she had
the rune of death at one point but she
was defeated by malekith and that was it
that's all we've got on her she seems
like an enormously important character
to understanding some pretty big pieces
of the history of elden ring like the
whole separation of destined death from
the world and the spawning of the golden
order but we have next to nothing on her
except for a handful of item
descriptions she was the leader of the
godskin apostles and used the god slayer
greatsword so clearly she was no friend
of the greater will or even queen
america since merica sent her own shadow
to kill the glomed queen which he did
but did she just disappear after that
was she absorbed into the rune of death
is she the rune of death aka destined to
death is destined to death melina is the
glomite queen melina we just don't know
and hopefully the dust guide queen is
one of the characters who will get
explored more in future dlc because
dammit i need answers number eight who
created the elden ring you know the
supernatural relic that governs the
lands between and the namesake of the
game eldon ring was it the greater will
since we know they sent the elden beast
which is the vassal of the elden ring to
the lands between in order to enter into
and possess america making her the
vessel of the elden ring or was it
another outer god predating the greater
will we actually have proof in game that
an elden lord existed long before the
age of the earth tree in the form of
fortasax the ancient dragon so does this
mean that the elden ring and therefore
the elden lords have always existed even
before the current age of the greater
will but that would conflict with the
fact that godfrey is said to be the
first elden lord in the age of the earth
tree again we just don't know next up
number nine hey we're getting close to
the end now happens at the end of the
game actually ratikin's whole hostility
towards the player tarnished when you
think about it is quite strange quite
strange indeed i mean if anything we are
to assume that radigan is on the same
side as america right i mean he left his
first wife to give america children and
then became her but not only does he
fight against you who america wanted to
return to the lands between he also
takes things a step further and closes
off the urge tree from entry to anyone
which is something that's pretty much
confirmed to be ratigan's doing since
his symbol is that crisscross pattern
that's shown to be sealing the archery's
roots from entry we can see that pattern
associated with him in his statues and
in his fight and on his scarceland
sorcelede talismans in fact the pattern
is even referred to here as a great rune
of the elden ring but if merica wanted
the tarnished to one day return and
battle their way up to the earth tree
and cleanse her body of the elden beast
controlling her that means that merica
definitely wanted the tarnished to enter
the roots of the earth tree and since we
also know that the greater will wanted
the tarnished to reforge the great runes
back into the elden ring which is
something told to us via the fingers via
enya that means that the greater will
definitely also wanted the tarnish to
approach the elden ring inside the earth
tree so both the greater will and
america wanted the tarnish to enter but
seemingly out of nowhere radigan seals
us out and also tries to kill us upon
our entry the question we're left with
is why ratigan is called the leel hound
of the golden order by america and his
title is ratigan of the golden order so
it's heavily implied that his loyalties
lie with the golden order which is to
say the vision of the greater will so
his prevention of both america's and the
greater wills plans is pretty mysterious
to say the least my personal opinion is
that he found out what america's plan
really was you know probably having the
tarnished rid herself of the elden beast
and therefore the control of the greater
will and disagreed with it wanting to
stop the tarnished from killing the
elden beast inside his slash her slash
their body which would remove the
greater will's connection to the world
but of course that's just my theory the
actual answer isn't explained anywhere
in game now before we get to the final
and biggest unanswered question of them
all here are a couple honorable mentions
because like i said this game is full of
vague storylines with no beginnings or
endings the first honorable mention is
an extremely interesting side character
known as nefelilo warrior this barbaric
lady is clad in the clothing of a
champion which you can also wear if you
start off as the hero class she's the
daughter of sir gideon the all-knowing
but you find out later that she's
actually not his blood daughter but
instead was simply adopted by the man
following her loss of the guidance of
grace the champion armor that she wears
is said to come from a people who
followed their chieftain hora lo you
know godfrey the first elden lord
gasp nephili lo horulo daughter without
confirmed blood father father with
several confirmed blood children warrior
warrior by no the connections seem
uncanny and that's not the end of them
either nephili low is also inexplicably
summonable for the fight against godfrey
slash horalo so i definitely think
they're connected by at least their clan
but whether or not this actually means
that nafeli's real dad was horror low
though is a complete mystery unconfirmed
but you knew that otherwise it wouldn't
be in this video the other honorable
mention is what is with the three
fingers i mean seriously is there a
significance to the fact that three plus
two equals five does it mean that each
outer god has a different kind of
fingers is there a one finger out there
a four fingers a five fingers a six
fingers who knows man who knows anyway
at the end of this list at number 10 the
most mysterious mystery of them all is
why was godwin killed if there's one
event besides the shattering of the ring
that was responsible for spawning the
events of the game and had its hand in
every story path that you can take
in-game it would be the cold-blooded
murder of godwin the golden we have
several reasons to believe that ronnie
was behind his murder but we also have
several reasons to believe that merica
his own mother was behind his murder but
we also have several reasons to believe
that the newman women aka the black
knife assassins acted independently and
murdered him by themselves but why him
what was so special about the firstborn
of the demigods and who himself was not
even an emperian that he had to die to
sate some unknown mastermind's plan and
furthermore why was he killed in the way
that he was with his body being left
alive but his soul being erased from
existence with the half curse mark
carved into him and then why was he
attached to the roots of the great tree
which i have recently discovered is not
the erd tree who orchestrated his body
being used to spread death root
throughout the land by way of the roots
of the great tree and why why would it
be so difficult to give us something
anything in regards to answering
anything about godwin's death and curse
mark o great and noble devs of fromsoft
once again all we can do is hope for
answers in a future dlc but for now
that's the end of my list of the top 10
most mysterious unanswered questions in
eldon ring plus a couple bonuses what
did you think of my list do you have the
answers to any of these questions or
maybe do you have other questions that
you feel need answers in a future dlc
let me know in the comments below and
also please leave a like below if you
enjoyed the video or at least my efforts
into making the video and subscribe if
you haven't already to stick around for
all sorts of gaming videos to come huge
thanks as always to my bandit crew who
make my day every day and are the reason
i continue bringing the worlds of video
games to your local youtube screens free
of charge that's all i've got in this
one so as always i hope you have a
wonderful rest of your day this is
bandit looking forward to seeing you
next time and signing out
[Music]
bye